[Music]
it might look cold but the winters here
in Sweden are becoming warmer climate
change means it's increasingly difficult
for these Sami herders to find the moss
and lichen under the snow that their
reindeer feed on warmer and more ice now
that winter has been so low so now the
unusual winter is a normal in November
2019 the European Parliament's declared
a climate and environmental emergency
historic signal from MEP s that Europe
is ready to act the European Union has
pledged to become climate neutral by
2050 and MEP s want to make the targets
along the way even more ambitious
element has been very vocal under this
mandate to ask for enhanced goals for
2030 today 40% what the majority wants
so far is 55% of co2 reductions in 2030
compared to 1990 we will see if we can
find an agreement soon which is very
very strong which soon with the country
because we cannot afford to waste time
at the heart of the European Green Deal
is the climate law which will make it a
bigger tree on the EU law to cut our
emissions we must build a sustainable
economy from Transport to industry to
agriculture the Green Deal investment
plan will mobilize at least 1 trillion
euros of public and private investments
over the next decade supporting green
technology jobs and infrastructure while
the just transition fund will ensure
that no one is left behind
helping people employed in unsustainable
sectors like coal to retrain for the
jobs of tomorrow what we eat and how we
consume is also key like producing more
sustainable food from closer to home
through the farm to fork strategy
protecting the biodiversity and the
pollinators which we rely on and
reducing our waste creating a truly
circular economy by reusing and
recycling the European Parliament will
be there at every step to make sure the
Green Deal turns Europe into a truly
green continent through ambitious laws
and has the necessary funding and vision
to live up to its ambitions
[Music]